près de 2 500 et viennois vacciner la
nocturne au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a eu du succès
une ouverture jusqu'à minuit ce vendredi
30 avril pour recevoir les patients en
activité j'ai très très bien très bien
parce que moins ça permet de venir en
dehors des horaires du boulot pour les
personnes qui travaillent qui
travaillent tard jusqu'à 18 19 heures
c'est une très bonne idée effectivement
23 ça permet de 500 dehors des heures de
bureau
c'est une bonne opportunité pour ceux
qui travaillent entre puis voilà ça
ouvre plus de créneaux quoi pour en
profiter l'agglomération note que 50%
des patients viennent de l'extérieur de
saint quentin en yvelines
pour cette première soirée ce sont des
doses faiza qui ont été administrés 500
primovaccination les gens qui
travaillent et bien ils ont ils
travaillent la journée et donc il faut
qu'ils viennent le soir donc voilà voilà
la raison et deuxièmement ça nous permet
à nous de nous préparer puisque bien
entendu on sent bien que ya plus de gens
de 50 ans que jude 60 donc mais sûr ça
va en quantité il faut se préparer à
augmenter bien sûr le nombre de
vaccinations
après cette première soirée test le
vélodrome sera en nocturne tous les
vendredis soirs depuis le 1er mai la
vaccination est ouverte aux français de
plus de 18 ans souffrant d'une ou de
plusieurs co morbidités